[Music]
uh
hello and welcome to one of our favorite
programs i'd like to know
this is our question and answer bible
program where we have the privilege and
pleasure of answering your bible-based
questions i'm c.a murray and i'm in the
company of my uh colleague and ministry
pastor daniel miranda danny good to have
you here thank you it's good to be here
pastor c.a we we brought in our
impressive list of questions that it's
getting longer uh weekly and we like
that it shows one that you are watching
two that you are getting the answers
that you need and desire and three uh it
gives us a chance to go into the word of
god so we thank you for that because
this is this is great fun to answer
questions from the word we've got a few
questions today uh we we we make you
this promise and we stated always at the
head of each program we want to answer
you from the word of god it's it's
really too late in the history of
mankind we are too close to the coming
of our lord and savior jesus christ
to be spewing out as it were the
opinions of men
you ask for answers from god's word your
questions are based on god's word and of
course our answers ought also to be
based on god's word so we make you that
promise that when a question is asked it
will be answered from the word of god if
an answer can be found we will try to
find it or we will find someone who can
and that is our privilege and our
pleasure pastor if you would begin with
prayer we will dive right into this
impressive list of questions but before
you do that let me let me just say this
should you want to be a part of this
program
never want to forget to allow the
opportunity to send in your own
questions to
tv
at some tv.org
that is tv at s-u-m as in mary tv dot
o-r-g and we will add your questions to
our list and promise
you that we will get to them uh there we
can pastor now if you would pray for us
yeah let's pray
most gracious heavenly father we thank
you for this blessed ministry and for
this wonderful program thank you for
those who are participating and sending
their questions i pray lord that your
holy spirit may lead us and guide us
into your word as pastor c.a said we
only want to
stick to your word and not to present
human opinions i pray lord that this
program may help answer the questions
that have been sent in the name of jesus
amen amen amen and amen
this question comes to us from dr
gatlock
jacques
md
he wishes us best regards and it's he's
got a fairly lengthy preamble but then
he gets right to the question and may we
ask and then of course this is not
prerequisite but perhaps if you are
writing from outside the country let us
know where
you are writing from it gives us
some idea of the reach of the ministry
the footprint as it were lets us know
who is watching from what country from
where in the world we get questions from
all over the world but if it's not too
much of an imposition if you could add
that little bit of information we would
certainly find that helpful uh for a
number of things and metrics that we are
trying to establish as we we try to do
what we can uh to answer questions from
around the world
um
i have a question first let me tell you
about my understanding of the issue as
an sda um he's got a whole paragraph
here so perhaps we won't we won't get
into that but get right to his question
because he says in isaiah
chapter 65 20 and we will read that
it seems like there is going to be death
or curse
while in the new earth those things will
never be present according to revelation
21 3 and 4 and revelation 22 3
and in isaiah 65 20. but
the bible seems to explain this in
context of a new earth
so what is your thoughts on
this as theologians well i don't know
about theologians but we are bible
students
[Laughter]
dan you want to take a look uh
run at this and and um
gatlock's question yeah sure um i think
you also have good points but
first of all we need when we study books
like the book of isaiah
and the book of jeremiah jeremiah
ezekiel
those books fall into the category
that some scholars call
the classical prophecies
what is a classical prophecy a classical
prophecy is a prophecy that is
conditional
that was when it was first given
it was given
to little israel
and it was expected to have a literal
fulfillment little local fulfillment
okay so you have many things in the book
of isaiah
that points
to
the immediate or let us not say the
immediate but the local and literal
condition of the people now from chapter
the last chapters of the book of isaiah
this is the last section
those are prophecies that apply directly
to the post-athelic
community of israel those who had
returned from babylon after the
captivity and god renews the covenant
with them and he promises them to set
them
as the light of the world and as a great
nation
even to the point of lengthening their
days yeah
so it is true that this kind of
prophecies classical prophecies
they also have dual fulfillment
and we have the book of revelation that
borrows a lot of language from this
particular passage for example in isaiah
65 17 it says for behold i create new
heavens and new earth and the former
shall not be remembered or come to mind
so this is the context of of verse 20
and this is very almost
verbatim uh passage from revelation
chapter
verse
1. but it is true and the bible is not
inconsistent
that there won't be death or curse in
the new heavens and the new earth so we
need to understand this text as a
conditional prophecy
that could have been fulfilled with
literal israel
if they had been faithful to the
covenant because even the covenant had
specifications about
dietary laws and and health laws so it
wouldn't even lengthen their day and
their span of life so that even kids
would know would not die very young
this is the way i understand it yes
well said i think when we're dealing
with with with these prophets um isaiah
jeremiah to a lesser extent ezekiel
there is a
and a sequence
to uh applying the prophecy some the
primary sequence is applied to literal
israel at the time the prophecy was was
written yeah or was enunciated then
there is a secondary application a
parallel application that can be applied
to
the prophecy
at the end of time
but the secondary application does not
include every nuance of the prophecy
if you get into the weeds as they say
the prophecy that's the primary
application but there are certainly
secondary parallels to almost everything
that isaiah said and of course once you
get past uh
55 up to the end you're dealing with
post-exilic prophecies you're dealing
with looking at the the coming of christ
and those kinds of things and so this
can be looked at in that way and then i
found something else
interesting in uh some notes that i had
on the my tanakh which is a hebrew bible
that says that these
prophecies
in these prophecies the word will
is almost equivalent to the word wood
so that when you're making that
secondary application
uh
a a child would die if a child did die
or would die at that age he would
consider curse so
the burden of the prophecy is this
that
god is going to restore israel
and then god is going to restore the
world when he comes again
and so
those things that deal with long life
and health and the banishment of sin
will be replied will can be applied to
israel once they've gone through their
exile and can be applied to the world
just prior to the coming of christ and
looking at the establishment of god's
kingdom those things are parallel and
are true yeah very good you know i was
just thinking as you were talking about
a good example that illustrates this and
is found in the book of ezekiel chapters
38 and 39 that has
caused quite a
bit of confusion among some christians
about the prophecies of gog and magog
that they try to apply to literal
for example to do they or even russia
and countries like that
but
again
revelation echoes gog and magog in
revelation chapter 20
but as you said
the the the second fulfillment or we
would say the second layer of this
prophecy doesn't
get all the details of the first layer
so for example here we find
in verse 9 of ezekiel 39 then those who
dwell in the cities of israel will go
out and set on fire and burn the weapons
both the shields and bucklers the bows
and arrows the jubilants and spears and
they will make fires with them
for seven years
um we know that this is not talking
about that armageddon is going to last
seven years
this is this could have been fulfilled
literally
if israel had fulfilled the conditions
in chapter 36 of the new covenant yes uh
they would awaken the wrath of this king
gog
in the land of magog but that never was
fulfilled no so revelation takes or
picks some aspects of this
and applies it to the end yes but not
with all the specifications about the
weapons they were going to use and the
time of war none of those things yeah
of all the books in interesting
revelation draws from about 65
old testament works but it draws them to
to create parallels yeah and to
elaborate on them and to show us that
there are parallels with with the old
testament times and what what the way
god acted with his people in old
testament time but if you try to
link up as you well said every
particular point it wasn't designed to
do that exactly it wasn't intended to do
that and they won't line up particularly
but if you look at the broad scope the
broad arc of of revelation you can see
parallels with the old testament amen
alrighty very good uh you've got the
second one
sure the second question comes from
jothan
masilla
and he greets us from kenya it brings to
you my brother
and it says here here is my question in
romans chapter 7 verse 14 through 25
paul says that he is sold under sin he
says that he is willing to do good in
his mind but he finds another law that
is against his will
so he's basically commenting on romans
chapter seven about the the the struggle
that paul was going through and then
this is this question
in verse 24 he cries
laments because of his weakness in verse
25 he thanks god for the deliverance but
now he says so then
with the mind i myself serve the law of
god but with flesh the law of sin
what does it mean by that what does he
mean by that
how does he serve the law the law of god
and the law of sin simultaneously please
help i think his question then is based
on
verse 25
of romans chapter 7.
so i think we should read the verse
first and then try to explain it
romans chapter 7 verse 25
it says i thank god through jesus christ
our lord
so then
with the mind
i myself serve the law of god
but with the flesh
the law of sin
this is a good question and it is an
interesting one
drawn from romans chapter 7. what i see
here is this
paul
in his letter to
the christians at rome
is
articulating
his struggle with sin right
and
the whole letter this this portion of
the letter must be seen in that context
he starts out this chapter i'm in 7-1
with this statement or do you not know
don't you know brethren
for i speak to those who know the law
that the law has dominion over a man as
long as he lives so that's the reality
that we're dealing with
the dominion of the law as long as he
lives now that puts flight to those who
say that once you come to christ you
have nothing to do with the law anymore
uh so this he starts out by telling you
the law has demanded over you as long as
you live all right
then in what i think are three key
verses
he orchestrates his struggle
to
serve the lord to fight with sin
in the context of the law defining for
him what sin is
so we look at at 7 12 and 14.
and there are other texts too but i i
think these tend to stand out for me
what shall we say then is the law sin
certainly not
on the contrary i would not have known
sin except through the law so he
establishes the law for me defines sin
it is not sin
but it defines what's in it correct all
right and verse 12
therefore
the law is holy
and the commandment holy
and just and good amen he's saying the
law is not sin it is to the contrast of
sin or to the contrary the law is holy
the law is just the law is good and
verse 14.
for we know that the law is spiritual
and this is the crux of his argument
but i am carnal souled unto
under sin then he talks about the
struggle things i want to do i don't do
things i know i shouldn't do i do do but
it's a consequence of the fact that the
law is spiritual
i am not i am carnal i'm trying to be
spiritual and the law aids me in that in
that it it creates the boundaries for
christian life it tells me when i'm
sinning it tells me when i'm slipping it
tells me when i'm going off the tracks
as it were the law defines for me sin so
if there was no law he's basis and there
would be no sin there would be no
knowledge of what sin in because because
sin is defined by the law and he is
saying
the law is good i am not that is the
basis of my struggle
very good very good point
i see here in romans chapter 7
an illustration of someone
who knows the law
but doesn't have the power from god to
obey the law
here in verse 9
paul says i was alive once without the
law
that means he didn't have the knowledge
of the law but when the commandment came
sin revived
and i died oh now this is a man that he
rejoices in the law of god he wants to
do the will of god
but he finds another law in his members
the law of sin which is sin itself the
transgression of the law
that fights against
the spiritual law yeah and he concludes
his argument
by saying
so then with the mind i myself serve the
law of god
but with the flesh
the law
of sin in what sense is he
serving the law of god
because the person hears that the key
word i believe is
is he serving the love of god and the
love sin simultaneously
well
god says or jesus himself said that we
cannot serve two masters
so there is not such a thing that we
serve
sin and we serve god simultaneously we
cannot serve two masters
but when it says here with the mind i
myself serve the love of god
is referring to his innermost desire to
do the will of god i mean in his mind he
was willing
to do it
because
as you mentioned for example verse 19
for the good that i will to do
i do not
but the evil i will not to do
that i practice
so with his mind he is wanting to do the
will of god but he finds himself
being
under
the flesh
so when he thanks god he is not thanking
god because he is serving the law of god
and and the flesh at the same time now
he's thanking god for what he is going
to mention in the next chapter yeah so
there is like a parenthetical
uh statement he's kind of
thanking god in advance because now he's
going to show uh what
the man
what what the experience is like about
walking in the spirit as we find in
chapter eight
i'm glad so very glad you went to
because i i was going to uh respond to
you from chapter 8.
because chapter 8 verse 1 there is now
therefore no condemnation to those who
are in christ jesus who do not walk
according to the flesh but according to
the spirit so that's the basis that's
everything else that follows exactly so
i jump down to let's go to verse six
for this for um
to be current for to be kindly minded is
death but to be spiritually minded is
life and peace because the carnal mind
is enmity against god for it is not
subject to the law of god north indeed
can be so those who are in the flesh
cannot please god and when i was reading
my mind
my my i jump back to verse five and six
also but he's he's giving you the point
that the the chrono mind can't be
subject to the it is not so
the the tension here is between the
flesh and the spirit exactly and uh he's
saying i'm subject to that tension uh
but he also gives you and the reason it
seems almost schizophrenic is because he
gives you glimpses of victory he tells
you of his struggle but he doesn't leave
you in that he tells you no there is
victory here
there is victory here through the law
because the law is holy and just and
good and when i submit myself to the law
then i i am i am in that state with god
so he starts out the next chapter there
is now therefore
no condemnation to those are in christ
jesus so rather than leave you in the
hole
of doubt he starts this next chapter
with a little bit of hope he goes back
to the struggle but it lets you know
there is hope uh if you're in christ
amen praise the lord i love that answer
yes so there is hope and chapter eight
of romans tells us clearly
that there is not such a thing of
serving the flesh and serving the spirit
at the same time
but when we have the spirit of christ
dwelling in us
then
we can crucify the flesh yeah and walk
in the spirit yes there is a subtext
that you just mentioned down here that i
want to just highlight before we leave
this
the idea that you cannot serve two
masters
that you cannot serve the flesh and the
spirit one has to be crucified right one
has to be put away with and it has to be
killed and can i say kept killed you
gotta keep on killing it you know you
got to fight that battle you never get
to put your christian experience on
autopilot you don't get to
sort of coast into the kingdom you've
got to actively fight that battle every
day of your life
and and you know the bible says those
who think they stand take heed unless
they fall so don't ever get to the point
where you can say i have arrived and i
have and this puts me you know your mind
goes out and grabs all kinds of things
i'm i'm thinking about um
first john
is it first john where he says we ought
to know that we have eternal life
in first second and third job or is it
is it second john
my brain is
playing games with me here
but it's it's it's the texture he says
you ought to know
that you have eternal life
um
so what i'm saying is you you cannot say
once i'm saved i'm always saved right
yet you ought to know that you're
walking with god and you're in a state
of peace with him
because it's important enough for god to
want you to know so the tension is
sitting back and saying well i got this
i'm i'm saved i don't have to work at
this
the other was the other side of the coin
is
knowing that you are walking with the
lord and
trusting in god's ability to save you
uh as long as you cooperate with him
so um uh it's it's hinted at here uh in
in romans uh but it's stated uh plainly
in john and that's that's the tension
that we as all christians have to labor
with sure the flesh wants one thing the
spirit wants another we have to yield to
the spirit amen
amen
all right we are moving along i guess
we've got time looking at the clock on
the wall one more question this is from
gudrun
gudrun gudrun
and tony
it does not say where they are from i do
not see
but
they have asked a question which has
kind of been in the air dad you know
it's it's around you know you hear it
whisper it in here people sort of
ruminating on it
they asked the question
i have heard it said
that the vaccine for covid 19
is
the mark of the beast
can you enlighten please
um
what say ye
i think it's a very simple answer
it is not the mark of the beast
[Laughter]
for for well some basic reasons i mean
when we go to the book of revelation you
know chapter 13 and chapter 14 yes
where we find
the mark of the beast
you know the mark of the beast it has to
do more with
a false system of worship thank you and
the third angels message
warns us against worshiping the image
and receiving the mark
of the beast
the covet
19 vaccine doesn't have anything to do
with worship
so
this does this does not apply
uh to any particular aspect of bible
prophecy
um also we we know
that uh
the mark of the beast
is formed after or is is is uh enforced
after the image
is formed and now you have to go and
study what the image of the beast is and
we understand that the image of the
beast has not been formed yet yes so if
the image is not formed then we cannot
have a mark yet and of course uh mark in
the in revelation is contrary to the
seal of god yes which is the sabbath so
uh there will be a false seal that this
beast is going to enforce to all the
world to worship
uh in a wrong and a false day a
counterfeit worship day that would be
the mark of the beast sunday as we
understand it as happiness yes but that
doesn't have anything to do with the
vaccine yes
so many things come to mind when you're
dealing with the beast as as you well
know you're you're dealing with
worship issues exactly in these last
days the the key issue is going to be
worshiped who are you going to worship
how are you going to worship when are
you going to worship why are you
worshiping so when we look at the beast
the beast the dragon the devil um
basically are almost interchangeable
it's either the devil himself
or an agency religious or secular that
he uses to promote his ends um and and
they all fall under that category and
you look at the the two beasts in
revelation 13 uh this land b seabees
when you look at the the beast uh in
revelation 14 when you look at uh the
illusions of the beast in revelation 18
they are all in the context of worship i
don't know how kovid
got to the exalted status of being
viewed as as the beast of the book of
revelation it's
it's a virus it's a pestilence uh
alluded to in matthew 24
no more no less but there are other
viruses and other pestilences that will
will come in time but the mark of the
beast is something very very
specific
so i will not let this
i don't want to say delusion but it
certainly is a distraction exactly
move us away from concentrating on what
the beast is doing and who the beast is
and um uh so it is not the mark of the
beast uh cannot be uh because the beast
is it has a whole different function in
our prophetic literature our time is
slipping away dan you've got a closing
thought
well um i think i'll highlight what you
said we should concentrate in more
important issues today
it's good that we ask these questions
but eventually we need to concentrate
more on jesus christ his salvation
his mission yes for us in this last days
praise the lord well our time has fast
slipped into eternity allow me in
closing to wish you both grace and peace
through our lord and savior jesus christ
we'll see you again soon bye bye and god
bless
[Music]
you